[Musique]
je suis un goéland je crois pas nos
corps fin et fuselées lé fils était un
martinet mais j'ai été élevé par des
goélands 12 as tu apprends lui à être
l'un des nantis tu as même pas sur ses
pattes
viens avec nous via allez viens
incroyable on va l'ensemble on ne fait
qu'un c'est vraiment magique
les martinets devrait rester de leur
côté du rocher cet avis tout le monde
m'a thereof sur sa présence dans le
groupe mais vous êtes ma famille ils ne
pourront jamais lui pardonner d'être un
martinet ne plus savoir où est sa place
ça arrive même aux meilleurs et
confiance en toi man ou une tempête se
préparer les goélands s'apprête à migrer
vous ne pouvez pas partir qu'est-ce que
tu entrais l'instant du martinet
on peut changer nos habitudes on est
tous des oiseaux
je suis un martinet